how often do you check your dms oh i
don't check my demons your gm's got to
be a dark place
[Music]
yeah i'm going to check my dm's i got a
man and i don't even mean like in i mean
obviously
random dick pics i'm sure are coming are
you flying through those just too weird
because it'll be like from
eight-year-old boys and [ __ ] and it's
like y'all making me uncomfortable
that's [ __ ] up can you imagine not
knowing what you're opening and then
it's an eight-year-old dick like
like y'all making me just want to delete
the whole app i would yeah i'm off
social media
yo that's like when i went on twitter
once and i saw tiger's dick on accident
i was like bro i did not sign up to see
tiger's dick
social media in general is just a lot of
times i had to like check out
and like just do something normal
because gotta get consumed in this like
virtual reality [ __ ] is it um
nice to be in a relationship when you're
going through the the stuff you're going
through in your career so you kind of
have like a safe place yes oh my god oh
my god like that's my [ __ ] safe zone
that's my sanity for real like that's
when i can come home
from the studio crying and just
overwhelmed with everything and i just
saw eight-year-old dick help me
hold me
um
that's dope no because i mean i'm
married and it's the same thing i think
like a strong relationship is very
important like it's you know if it's a
strong relationship if it's toxic it can
also get you [ __ ] up because that [ __ ]
can just be too much like i didn't been
in a toxic relationship where it just
does nothing for you now this is that
[ __ ] like this the one so i know
what it feels like to have that like
safe space